[Musique]
on n'oublie jamais celle qui nous vole
un baiser
mais celui qui nous fait re dois mon
instinct me dit qu'il se passe un truc
grave là bas et mekhout nous disent
d'aller voir
très mauvaise idée et mitch on est
maître nageur nos moi mes couilles elles
disent si on la joue et relax moi mes
couilles
elles disent ferme ta gueule et allons
voir ce qu'il m'a creek où ils me font
chier c'est ben watt fonctionne ce que
nous respectons les consignes fait péter
les chiottes
bella
c'est une cata ce mec
je suis ma demande y est j'ai l'air d'en
avoir quelque chose à [ __ ] c'est un
des nageurs les plus doués du monde
c'est comme si un humain avait baisé
avec un jet ski
ce qui est impossible bien sûr mais ce
serait trop cool
c'est henri interdite se branler dans
des draps et n'oublie pas j'ai des yeux
partout
[ __ ] et au apprenez lui les bonnes
manières et musées vous mais ça passe à
l'heure du torrent voirie
m
vu les circonstances les choses auraient
pu être graves pire
après un match ça porte bonheur aux
fouilles et la morgue pour trouver des
preuves
voici à des traces de piqûres sur le
périnée je me demande de faire quoi je
lève ces bourses et vérifie ok c'est un
périnée regarde mieux ça y est je vois
un trou annoncées sont trop balcer
tunise je vais le post est interdite
parce qu'il sait jamais les mains
pleines de bolbec watch alerte à malibu
vous avez des cônes et le port de
plaisance c'est pas les x games et du
sauvetage en mode interpellation au
hockey poteau pour moi à part que c'est
du foutage de gueule de sauvetage en
mode interpellation au cinéma le 21 juin